MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Hello and welcome
to "What's New in
Google Play Services,"
and the first thing
we want to know
is, are you enjoying Google I/O?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That was
even better than I thought.
Are you enjoying Google I/O?
[APPLAUSE]
That's great.
We're loving Google I/O.
Google I/O is great.
It's like having one of
those birthday parties
when you were a child.
It's exciting.
It's something to
look forward to.
It's a big party.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
you know, sometimes I
feel like working at I/O is like
one of his birthday parties.
It's lots and lots of work but
it's a whole lot of fun, too.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And
speaking of fun, today,
we're going to talk
about something which
is a lot of fun,
building great apps
and using a key
technology in doing so,
Google Play Services, because
if you use Google Play Services,
you will build better apps.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Because today, there
are now more than 17 top level
APIs in Google Play Services
and we're adding new
capabilities all the time,
and these APIs are available
to you as a developer
so that you can build these
better apps that Magnus
is talking about.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And
Google Play services
are being pushed to more
than a billion devices
for each release.
That means that your audience
is a massive one where
you can promote yourself
and your business.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
that leads you to earning.
Did you know that in the
last 12 months alone,
developers of Play Store apps
have earned over $7 billion?
And this is what we believe
is a great demonstration
of the economies of scale
that are available for you.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And
it doesn't stop there.
Since last year, we have
released five new versions
of Google Play services.
That's one release
almost every second month
packed with new
functionality for you
to use when you
develop your apps.
LAURENCE MORONEY: But our
question to you is this.
Are you capitalizing on
this massive opportunity?
Are you thinking mobile first
and are you using Google
Play Services to think mobile
first in your development?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Because at Google,
we are super committed
to the mobile revolution,
and a big part of
that is to provide
all of these great services
that we have in our data centers
running all over the world.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
a big looking data center.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: It is a
nice looking data center.
And take all of those
services and make
them available on all of the
mobile devices out there.
And we are pretty good
at building data centers,
so we have lots of value there
to provide to mobile devices.
And Google Play Services is
the key integration layer
that makes this possible
between the data
center and the mobile device.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Because this
helps us as Google and you
as application developers to
push the boundaries of what's
possible together.
And as Henry Ford once said,
"If everyone is moving forward
together--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: --success
takes care of itself."
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Wait a second, Magnus.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: What now?
LAURENCE MORONEY: We've
forgotten something.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Oh no.
What did we forget?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
We're not just doing
a list of all the stuff
that's in Google Play Store.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Oh, that's right.
We're also handing
out some swag.
Are you interested in swag?
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You can take it.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm worried.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Let's
see how this works now.
So this is the way
this is going to work.
At various parts of this
presentation, we will go out
and we will say,
"Google Play Services,"
and then you will say, "rocks."
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
it's in Comic Sans font,
too, if you've noticed.
We actually got to use
that in a presentation.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Are
you ready to try that?
All right.
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Great.
Let's try that one more time.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This
one's going to go far.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Is
this really packed?
LAURENCE MORONEY: This
one's really packed.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Oh my.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Anybody
got a catcher's mitt?
Let's try a different one.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: We
could try it like this.
I mean, we can try.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Let's see what happens.
Let me just hide
behind the podium.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Are you
ready in the front row?
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Whoa.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Whoo.
Bullseye.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: There you go.
OK.
Let's keep this party going.
And what can be a better
place to start than games?
Have you ever tried to
set up a multi player game
and had technical challenges?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh gosh, yeah.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's a pain.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
It's terrible, right?
You're fiddling around
with the controls.
You can't find
the configuration.
Well, the Nearby Connections
API solves all of that.
It just takes technology
completely out of the way
so you and your friends
can focus on the fun.
It turns every smartphone
into a flexible controller,
and since it's a
touchscreen, you
can use any types of controls.
You're not bounded by
these physical things
that you see in consoles.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So I could
use this instead of an Xbox
controller?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Exactly.
It's a remote controller.
And then you can
display the game action
on a central screen
like a big tablet
or an Android TV or something
like that, for example.
And of course, this thing is
not limited to just games.
It can be used for any
type of apps out there.
Another thing that we launched
for Play Game Services
is Play Game
Analytics, essentially
a analytics platform built
into all of the games
that you create that
helps you to get data
to understand your players,
to manage and set your revenue
targets, and also identify
hotspots in your game.
These are three key things
to monetize on your game,
and those things were previously
done only by big studios
with big budgets.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I don't have
to do any kind of
development, right?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No.
There is no coding whatsoever.
All of this is
automatically recorded
when you use these APIs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And while
mobiles like this are great,
the thing that makes
them really portable,
this tiny little screen,
can be a limitation
when you want to share
content with your friends.
It's hard to huddle over
a small screen like this.
As a result, we released
Cast and the Cast SDK
that would allow you to
reflect this on a big screen
like the ones behind me.
Now, in addition to that,
in the last 12 months,
we released something called
the Remote Display API,
and what the Remote
Display API does
is it removes the
boundary of mirroring
that you would have to have.
So now you can drive independent
content on this screen
and on that screen.
And as a result,
like maybe Magnus,
we're both big hockey fans.
Any hockey fans here?
[APPLAUSE]
Nice, nice.
So Magnus and I are
both big hockey fans,
and we could be watching
a game on the big screen
and chatting with each
other on our small screen,
and I could be telling him how
all those Swedish players suck.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: They are great.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh Magnus, sorry.
It's your turn to talk.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Oh.
I see.
Many times I've thought, if
I build it, they will come,
and that's really,
really tough, isn't it?
And it's not even enough, right?
You also have to monetize on
the stuff that you're building,
right?
You have to earn money in
order to improve your game
and for your business to grow.
So therefore, mobile ads
is a perfect way to do this
and it is at no
cost to the user.
So the Ads team that
we have, they're
working really,
really hard on making
all of those mobile
ads as relevant
as possible to the user.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So does that mean
if we're watching
our hockey game,
I'm not going to
get ads for diapers?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No, you're not
going to get ads for diapers.
You're going to get sports ads.
So this means that users will
get relevant ads, ads they will
actually be delighted to see.
And if the users are getting
delighted by the ads,
then the advertisers
will be delighted,
and you as app developers
will also be delighted.
A win, win, win.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And a constant pain
point when you're building
applications is managing
sign-in for your users.
It's a pain for you
because you have
to build the
infrastructure and you
have to secure that
infrastructure for signing
folks in, and it's a pain for
your users to remember yet
another username and password.
What do I use to
sign into this app?
sign into that app?
One of the things we've
shipped in Google Play services
is Sign In with Google, and the
idea behind Sign In with Google
is it manages all
of that for you.
Your users have a
much better experience
because they can just use their
existing Google IDs to sign in
and they don't have to remember
a whole new set of credentials,
and you end up having the
security of knowing that you've
got this great bulletproof
infrastructure behind you
so you don't need to
build everything that's
needed to actually
support these end users.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Swag break.
Now Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Whoa.
How about that?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You almost got him.
So hang on.
I think we've got a really
quiet crowd here today.
Who wants Magnus to shoot
a T-shirt your away?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Which side is louder?
Is it this side?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Or is it this side?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Whoa.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Maybe give
these two-- is it this side?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Or is it this side?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh boy.
That's close.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: I think per
person, they're louder here.
Let's go here.
Here we go.
Whoa.
LAURENCE MORONEY: When I
rehearsed this yesterday,
I ended up throwing
the remote by accident,
so I have to be really careful
not to throw it this time.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: All right.
Now turning to an
API that I think
is a hidden gem in the
Google Play Services
family, Google Drive.
Did you know that every single
user of Google on the planet
has 15 gigabytes of storage
available right there free
of charge and ready to use?
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
a lot of gigabytes.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah, 15 gigs.
How can your app help
them use that storage?
With Google Drive, Sign In for
Google, all of that capacity
is sitting right there already
authenticated and ready
for your app to use.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
in addition to that,
you can take advantage
of analytics,
and analytics isn't just
about crunching numbers.
Really, it's about understanding
your users so that you
can continually delight them.
Let me give a
couple of examples.
If you built a mobile app that's
got a lot of screens in it,
a lot of the time,
your users are going
to be leaving after one screen.
Maybe it's your game
over screen in a game
or maybe it's your
hockey app where
as soon as they show
the Swedish players,
everybody wants to leave.
Sorry, Magnus.
You can actually use
analytics to track this
and you can see what it is about
my app that's causing people
to leave, and I can
follow up on that
and maybe improve
my app in that way.
Or my personal favorite
is when it comes
to localizing my application.
Now, it's easy to make a finger
in the air estimate and say,
the next language
I need to have is
French or Spanish or Mandarin
Chinese or something like that.
But when using
Google Analytics, I
might find out hidden
knowledge that maybe my app
is the most popular app
in Turkey or Armenia
or some other country
like that and it
would be smarter for
me to localize it
so that one to delight
my users in that country.
There's just so many ways
that you can do this.
There's so many
ways that you can
understand your users so
that you can continually
delight them.
I'm an analytics geek.
I could just talk
about it all day.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: No,
no, no, no, Laurence.
Let's not do that.
I mean, we have lots
of stuff to cover here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We've got
Google Play Services, right?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Let's instead
talk about Android Pay.
Mobile payments are
hot, if you didn't know,
and Android Pay is
the technology that
makes this physical thing that
we carry around us every day,
and it gets bigger and
bigger for every year
as you pile up additional
credit cards and loyalty
programs into it, make
all of that content
be integrated into
your mobile device.
So that's from a
user perspective,
but for you developers,
there's also great value
because Android Pay brings
money into your app.
It allows you to deal with
trading physical goods
and get paid for them.
There's also an
aspect, if you're
developing apps for charity,
where you can donate money
using Android Pay.
So if you think about
this, what Android Pay does
is it takes the physical
world of commerce
and taking that into
the digital world,
and your app is sitting
right there in the middle,
connecting the user
and the merchant.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
talking about connecting
the dots, another technology
that's in Google Play Services
is Google Cloud Messaging.
And if you've ever
wanted to build
some kind of infrastructure
that provides notifications
to your users and asynchronous
notifications that gets synced
across all of their
devices, you've probably
realized this is pretty hard
to do in a way that's easy
and it's pretty hard to do in
a way that's battery friendly,
but if you build with
Google Cloud Messaging,
you'll get exactly all of that.
It's all about asynchronous
messaging from the cloud
to your users and it's
at zero cost to you.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hey.
What did you say?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Zero cost to you.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Zero cost?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Zero cost.
You can keep your
wallet in your pocket.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: How
can it be zero cost?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Because we're awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
So we've added the concept
of Topics to this recently,
and if you've used Google
Cloud Messaging Topics,
and we saw a little bit of it
in the keynote this morning.
And the idea behind
Topics is that you
can set types of messages that
your users will subscribe to.
So for example, I live
up north in Seattle
near the Canadian
border, and I love
on weekends during the winter,
because I manage a hockey team,
to go across into Canada and
get slaughtered at hockey.
But if I'm in that
country, and maybe
you've built a news application,
and your news application
is going to be delivering
news to an American audience
and your news application
could be delivering
to a Canadian audience.
I could pick the topic
of Canada and just
subscribe to news in that.
And those kind of topics just
make it a lot more portable,
make it a lot easier to
use, and like we said,
it's at zero cost to you.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
And for Maps, we
added a new toolbar
that gives users
that you have access to
navigation immediately.
Lite mode maps are also
introduced into the mobile API,
allowing you to display
a lighter version of Maps
if you don't need the full
blown maps experience.
And combined with--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
--location, then you
can start thinking
in terms of building
hyper-local applications.
And you've probably
used Location
and you're probably familiar
with Location Services
and apps, but one
really cool thing
that's been added
in the last year
is the concept of an in
place location dialog.
And the idea behind this
is if you've ever opened up
an app that uses location,
and if you're like me,
you turn Location
off to save battery,
and you open up the app and
it says, "Location services
are turned off.
Please enable them."
So you exit the app,
you go into Settings.
You find Location in Settings,
you turn on Location.
You then exit Settings,
you go back to your app,
and it's like--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's awful.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It is.
It's a lot of work
for the user and it's
very user hostile, right?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Shall we have
a moment of silence for that?
But now with the In
Place Location dialog,
the idea is you as
a developer, if you
use this in your application,
that pain for the user
just goes away and you
make their experience
that much better.
Uh oh.
It's time for a--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's good.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Oh, nice catch.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's
a pretty good one.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
Got one more?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah,
I've got one more.
Anyone want some swag?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
See if you can hit
the cameraman with this one?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: This is one
of those, again, that can hit
the control tower over there.
So 300 PSI.
That's going to be great.
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Whoa.
Nice.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That
went way over there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
a lot of new stuff
that we've spoken about.
That was a good shot.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
It's great.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
There's so much more
that we can talk about.
Why don't we, David
Letterman style,
do a top five countdown
of some of these things?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That sounds great.
Yeah, let's do that,
but we're developers.
It needs to be a 0x5 countdown.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's right.
We've got to do it in hex.
But then again, as
we're developers,
we should start
counting from 0x4
because engineers count from--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Zero.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, that's right.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Let's try that again.
Because engineers count from--
AUDIENCE: Zero.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Much better.
So I think it's
great to have apps,
and I love some of the apps
that I have on my phone,
but sometimes discovering
apps can be very difficult.
So for me, it's great
that I find crazy hockey
apps that Magnus gives me
or those irritating tap,
tap, tap games-- you know the
ones that I'm talking about--
that my son usually
gives me, and a great way
to discover new apps is through
friends and through family
and through people
that you trust.
So we picked number 0x4
on our countdown to be
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: App
Invites, where friends
help friends find great apps.
Apps Invite provides
you with an API
as developers that can
percent a simple UI for which
the users of your app can
invite other users to install
the app as well.
So I'm, for example,
using an app,
of course, where I can see
Swedish hockey players,
so this allows me to invite
my friends to use this app.
My friends get the invite,
they install the app,
they engage with the content.
Everybody wins.
And in particular, you,
the application developer,
wins, since you get free word
of mouth marketing for your app.
There is nothing better than
a friend referral of your app.
And of course, there
are controls in place
to protect the user
experience for this.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So shall
we celebrate the App Invites
API with a--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That sounds good.
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm
going to show some love
to this side of the room.
You folks ready?
This thing's got a
bit of recoil, so.
Whoa.
Almost.
Shall we do one more?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Anyone
want one of these?
Good catch over there.
He I gave it away.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, so
when Magnus reached the back
of the room, it was at 300 PSI.
I've just put it to 600.
No, only kidding.
Whoa, nice.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Watch the screens.
All right.
And we've already spoken a
bit about maps and location
and the importance of having
an accurate location to offer
the best possible services, but
it's not all about location,
right?
It's about places, and there's
no place like home, right?
So therefore, 0x3 on
our countdown list is--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
The Places API,
and there really is
no place like home,
or if you've watched
me on YouTube,
there's no place like
the nearest coffee shop,
and that's what the
Places API is all about.
It's got over 100
million locations in it,
and we saw lots of cool
stuff about the Places API
and the things that you can
do with Places in the keynote
this morning.
One story I like to tell
was a couple of days ago,
I've been to San
Francisco so many times
and I've never been to
the Golden Gate Bridge.
So a couple of days ago, I went
to check out the Golden Gate
Bridge, and it's beautiful
and it's an awesome thing.
And I was using an
app that showed me
that there was some latte
art in a coffee shop
that wasn't too far away and
I had to go check it out,
and this was the
kind of thing that I
discovered from an app that
was using the Places API.
So think about your app
and the kind of things
that you can do in your app.
You can give your users
access to what's available
all around them at this
moment in time, particularly
when they're not at home, when
they're traveling somewhere.
They can discover
new things that
will actually delight them.
And it's great to build
a generic app that
has coffee shop details or ski
run details or ice rink details
or anything like that.
When you can build
one that takes
advantage of this rich
information about all
of these places, over
100 million places,
think about how you can delight
your users with apps that
do that, and the time to
build apps that does this,
I believe, is right now.
So are we going to celebrate?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
So let's celebrate.
Yes, the Places API.
Am I doing this right now?
I'm kind of forgetting
as I go along here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Have you
cranked it all the way up?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm
going to hide again.
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That
came in pretty fast.
This is not an exact
science by no means.
It all depends how
you tape the shirts.
Anything can happen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We had so
much fun preparing for this.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Here we go.
Good catch over there.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, and is
that a Portland Trailblazers
hat I see?
AUDIENCE: Browns.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Cleveland Browns,
and you can catch a ball.
Nice.
And this brings us to number
0x2 on our countdown, which is--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: App Indexing.
With more and more apps
coming out every day,
it's getting harder and
harder for the users
out there to discover your app.
App Indexing solves
this by providing you
with the capability to take
specific content in your app
and surface that
through this API
and make it part of the
Google Search Engine Index.
That means that users that are
using Google search out there
searching for this
type of content
can actually discover your apps.
It's a great new feature,
and the search integration
goes even beyond this.
Your users can now
engage with your app
through Google Voice
Search commands.
So for example, OK, Google.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Search
restaurants nearby?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Search for
restaurants or hotel nearby.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm hungry.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
I'm hungry, too.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
don't have any food,
so I think I'm just
going to celebrate
by launching some swag.
What do you think?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That sounds good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So can we
have a Google Play Services?
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Oh.
That's going to hit the screen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
All righty.
One more?
Let's try this side of the room.
Can we have a Google
Play Services?
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Almost the camera.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I wasn't
aiming at the camera, honest.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Were you aiming?
LAURENCE MORONEY: No.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hey, Laurence.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: What's
up with this countdown?
There's so much stuff and
we still have two left.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's true, yeah.
Well, that just
shows how much good
stuff we put into Google
Play Services, right?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
So what now?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Number two,
or number 0x1 on our countdown,
is Google Fit.
Google Fit is really about
getting all of your fitness
data in one place.
Think about the possibilities
for knowing yourself
that come from integrating
all of this data.
In the not too distant past,
you might have had a heart rate
sensor or you might have had a
pedometer or you might have had
a cool app that
measures your bike
ride or a different cool
app that measures your run,
but think about what happens
when you bring all of this
together.
What was your heart
rate like when
you were cycling up a hill?
What was the impact on your
body when you were ice skating?
Think about all the ways that
you can bring this together.
That new diet, Magnus, it's
looking good on you, buddy.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: I don't know.
LAURENCE MORONEY: These kinds
of things you can learn.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: I don't
think it's working.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Fit gives you access
to all of these different
types of sensors
that I was talking about.
It gives you access
to a Recording API,
and the idea behind
the Recording API
is that you can smartly automate
want to record and when.
It gives you access
to a History API,
and the nice thing
about the History API
is you can then do a deep
dive into the historic data
around your health,
and maybe you'll
discover trends that weren't
apparent to begin with.
My personal favorite
is the Sessions API,
and the idea behind
the Sessions API
is it allows you to measure
fitness data in different ways
at different times.
I'll give an example.
My son runs track for his
team, and he's actually
running in a track meet right
now, so after the session,
I've got to find how he did.
In the 400 meters race,
he can do 400 meters
in a little under 60
seconds, but his fitness data
while he's doing that
400 meters race is vastly
different than his
fitness data in the hours
that he's training
for that race.
And with the Sessions
API, one could
build an application
that's optimized
for a scenario such as that one.
And then another one which is
really, really cool, of course,
is Custom Data Type.
So maybe somebody
here is an expert
on unicycling and the
impact that unicycling
has on the body-- we've
got one at the back.
Are you an expert on unicycling?
Nice.
Or maybe you're an expert
on ice skating or something
else like that.
So things that we
haven't thought about,
things that we
haven't built in, you
can actually extend using
these custom data types.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: All right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Time to celebrate?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
Should we celebrate Google
Fit with Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That actually hit
exactly where I wanted it to.
All right.
Let's try another one.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Whoa.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Nice
catch over there.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So we're getting
to the end of our
countdown and we've
reached number one, or
0x0, as we like to call it.
Any C++ developers here?
That's not a null pointer.
So we've reached the
top of our countdown.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Yeah, that's right,
and our number one feature
is something that brings
all of these things together.
It is Android Wear.
We introduced Android wearables
at Google I/O last year
and boy, has it come
a far way since.
If you haven't looked
into Android Wear
and you're not developing
for Android Wear,
you really need to
start because this
is a new computing
paradigm that is just
off its starting blocks.
You can now, for example, attach
any number of wearable devices
together with your phone.
I've got two devices
right here that are
paired with my phone over here.
And the new Channel API
and the Capabilities API
allow all of these devices
to talk in real time
and also transfer
files between them.
And the Capabilities API
allows each of the nodes
to surface the capabilities they
have, for example, if they have
connectivity to the internet.
And the devices are getting
more and more capable out there.
For example, just
now, a couple of hours
ago, the Maps API was launched
for Android Wear in the Android
Wear SDK, and that
allows for you
building native wearable
applications that
use the Maps API directly.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's pretty cool.
So while I'm navigating,
I can see it on my wrist.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's amazing.
It's thanks to
these advancements
in sensors, et cetera.
Also, as you heard
in the keynote,
Google Fit now also supports
squats, sit ups, and pull ups,
in addition to running,
bicycling, and walking.
So all of these capabilities are
there also to detect activity.
And all of these
sensors are getting
better and the mobile
SDK we're enhancing
all the time to take advantage
of these new hardware
improvements.
All these things, they are
transforming the wearable
to something beyond just
an extension of the phone,
so get on board
the wearables train
because it's sure
to change the way we
humans and technology interact.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
should we celebrate
the wearables platform,
our null pointer, the 0x0?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Absolutely.
This is the first place.
Go ahead.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This is
my favorite color t-shirt.
I want to keep this one.
Let's have a Google
Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: All right.
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: One more.
I'll stay away from the
camera man with this one.
Google Play Services.
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Oh, it's
going to hit the screen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It did
actually hit the screen.
Wasn't me.
Can we scroll the
notes down a little?
So when your users can find
new things that they love--
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Are continually
delighted by your app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: When they
can connect with each other
and the technology just
gets out of the way.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Can put
the content on any screen.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
When your users
have gigabytes of free storage
that they can access anywhere.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Can
securely sign into your app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: They can
easily, quickly, and safely
make payments online.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And are
always in the moment,
immediately informed of
what they want to know.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
When your users
are hyperlocally connected to
the world that they live in.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Find the
content that they desire.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Have all
of their bio and fitness
information in one place.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And are
connected to the distributed
wearable computing revolution.
When your users are doing
all of these things,
then you are developing
using Google Play Services.
There is a huge
greenfield of opportunity
here to develop,
engage, and earn.
If you look at all
of these things
that we've talked about
today, all of these APIs,
and start to imagine what you
can do when you combine them
together, it's going to
be something fantastic.
We really look forward to
see what gets out there
in the next 12
months, and if it's
anything like the previous ones,
then you'd better buckle up.
It's going to be
a heck of a ride
because Google Play Services--
AUDIENCE: Rocks.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
So we have a few
microphones set up
for questions and there's a
little bit more swag for folks
who have questions, so if you
have any questions for Magnus
or if you have any
questions for Magnus, just
please ask them with
the microphones.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Stop it.
Also, please provide feedback
to the session using these links
over here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we
have some of the folks
from the Google Play Services
team at the back here.
Can you give us a wave?
So if you've got any
questions for those folks too,
they're going to be
here and they're also
going to be in the Code
Labs area at the back.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: These
are the engineering folks
at Google Play Services, so
take advantage of asking them
technical questions.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And we might
have to pull some of them
up there if we can't
answer some questions.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Go ahead, sir.
AUDIENCE: Can you just
talk about the relationship
between Android Pay
Wallet, Instant Buy,
Buy With Google,
all these things?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
So Android Pay, you
can look at that as an
extension of Google Wallet.
It's a Google Play
Services component.
When you look at
Instant Buy, that's
not an API directly connected
to Google Play Services.
It's outside to deal
with virtual goods, not
physical ones, so if you're not
dealing with physical things,
so to say.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Maybe this side.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I've set up app
indexing in my Android app,
and I was wondering how long
does it take for those things
to start getting indexed?
When will you start seeing those
being surfaced in Google search
results?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
That's a good question.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm not
sure of the specifics,
but it should be pretty fast.
How long ago did you set it up?
AUDIENCE: At least
a few weeks ago.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: You
should take that offline.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Talk to these guys at
the back to check up.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: But it's
not an exact science,
as all things with
Google search.
AUDIENCE: So it's black box.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: It
does its crawling.
But certainly, we can
follow up with somebody
that's more technically capable
to answer that question.
All right.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
How about this side?
AUDIENCE: I saw that you had
the voice integration that you
could use the same way
that you use Google now
but inside of the application.
Is that limited
to just the search
functionality or can you use
that to launch other things
or do other types of
actions in the app?
LAURENCE MORONEY: There's
a limited set of keywords
that you can do with it right
now, but that set of keywords
is being extended,
and there's also
some keywords that are white
listed that you can check
with the folks to get it used.
And definitely, the folks
at the back of the room,
if you have a specific
keyword that you
want to have triggered
in there, they'll
be able to lead you
and help you with that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
But search x and y
will work for any of them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm from Hong Kong.
You just mentioned that Android
Pay is similar to Google Wallet
but is for physical goods.
So are we going to have
the same profit sharing
scheme, that is, 30%
of the payment amount
have to give to Google?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Sorry.
Can you repeat the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We are developers, so when
we doing in-app purchase
using Google Wallet, 30%
of the payment amount
will be taken by Google
Pay or by Google Wallet.
So is this the same amount,
same proportion, on Android Pay?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
We can't answer.
Come to us afterwards.
We'll find the person that can
answer that question for you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
That's a good question, though.
My understanding is that
the pay for selling goods
and that kind of thing is
separate from the amount
that you pay for
in-app purchases
or for app store purchases
and that kind of thing.
My imagination would be
that it's somewhat different
but I don't know
the exact figure.
Maybe this side.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are you guys doing anything
with the Location APIs
in order to add more
inputs to a fused location
provider, such as
indoor location
mapping or any other sensors?
LAURENCE MORONEY: We're
working on this all the time.
We're actually adding and
looking into new stuff
all the time but we don't
have any actual specific ones
that we can announce
at this time.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: So for the Invite
API, is there any way
to detect a closed loop?
So if I invite anybody,
is there any way
you are going to notify me that
the people I invited, someone
of those downloaded
the app or not?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's a good question.
I don't know.
So to repeat the question,
when I invite somebody,
I want to know if they've
accepted the invite or not.
I really don't know but let
me check on that one for you.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: That's
a detailed question
for App Invites.
Come, and we can
find somebody that
can answer that to you also.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Because you don't
want to keep asking them again
and again and again, right?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, thanks.
Maybe this side.
AUDIENCE: Hello, guys.
I know that it's now possible
to connect to an iPhone device
to Android Wear and to
receive all the notifications
from iPhone to Wear.
Will you expand the
framework to work
with Wear for iOS applications?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Future looking stuff we can't
really comment on right now,
but I would say if you
want to understand Wear
and how Wear works
with iPhone, it's
best to speak with the
engineering folks, the guys
in the red shirts at the back.
So sorry.
We can't speculate
on future stuff.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: If anyone
of you engineering folks
down there know the answers to
a question, just raise your hand
and we'll just hand
it over to you, OK?
LAURENCE MORONEY: We'll just
do that for every question.
How about in the middle here?
AUDIENCE: So my question
is also about App Invites.
How does that work
specifically for games
when you want to invite a
contact of yours or something
via games?
Is that through Google
Play Game Services?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
To my knowledge,
it would be exactly the same
thing as any application
app stored in Google
Play, regardless
of whether you use Play
Game Services or some
of the other APIs.
LAURENCE MORONEY: They'll
receive an email invite
with a link to it
in the Play Store,
and then they can just
click on it to install
it, that kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: So it's
all through email?
LAURENCE MORONEY: It
can be through email,
and I believe it's
also through IMs.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: You can
invite through Google Contacts,
you can invite
through email and SMS.
Am I correct here?
Yep, I'm correct here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This stuff
is so hot off the press.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Yeah.
This is released today, I think.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks.
This side.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask, how
are you keeping the Android
payment credentials secure?
Are you using secure element?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Come up afterwards
and we'll find the person.
LAURENCE MORONEY: That's
a really good question.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: This is
the problem with Google.
We have to realize we're
dealing with 12 APIs here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Over 17.
That's what I said
in the presentation.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Over 17 top level
APIs if you look
at the packages.
Correct.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
one of those things
that this is just so new off
the presses we don't have
the specific technical details.
I'm sorry.
Last one on this side.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are the invitations limited
only to applications?
For example, I saw a good movie
or I listened to a good song.
Can I send a recommendation
to a contact?
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: App
Invites to my knowledge
is limited to apps, but
you as an app developer
decide which content actually
triggers the app invite.
So if you have
content in your app
that you're interested in
telling your friends about
and that they engage through
your app to get that content,
you can actually deep link to
that content within your app
as part of the app
invite process.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Well, thank you, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Thank
you so much for attending.
[APPLAUSE]